À travers les époques
Les dangers
Une grande aventure les appelle
C'est l'épopée temporelle
Comme on se retrouve...
Tu te rappelles de Thomas,
qui a traversé le temps
avec le robot KB-28 ?
Ou plutôt Eliot,
comme il aime se faire appeler.
Mais si !
Ils sont à la recherche d'Iris,
et ça tombe bien,
car ils la retrouvent
saine et sauve,
assise sur un trône
dans un château au Moyen Âge.
Pas le genre d'endroit
où tu recroises une ex !
N'est-ce pas, Thomas ?
- Iris ?
- Thomas ?
Mais qu'est-ce que tu fous là ?
Non, toi !
Toi, qu'est-ce que tu fous là ?
Iris, il y a un problème.
Attendez, pourquoi le robot
à café de mon père et mon ex
se retrouvent au Moyen Âge
dans mon château ?
Ça me fait tellement plaisir
de te voir, Iris !
Ma reine,
connaissez-vous ces intrus ?
Voulez-vous qu'on les élimine
sur-le-champ ?
Oui, oui... Enfin, non !
Oui, je les connais,
et non, on les tue pas.
Tu vas rire, mais je pensais
que tu m'avais quitté.
Oh, putain...
T'es juste
dans une autre époque.
Mais t'inquiète pas, ma chérie,
je te ramène dans le présent.
Oh là là, Thomas, je voulais
éviter cette situation.
Désolé d'interrompre
les retrouvailles.
Iris, il y a un problème
avec le Docteur Simon.
Attends, KB-28,
t'as dit quoi sur mon père ?
Oui, bon, kidnappée ou tombée
dans une autre époque,
on s'en fout !
Le plus important, c'est que...
Oh, non...
On est ensemble,
et on retourne chez nous.
Non, Thomas,
on n'est plus ensemble.
Iris, le Docteur Simon
a disparu.
KB-28, c'est normal
que mon père ait disparu,
il voyage dans le temps.
Attends, Iris...
Il a inventé la machine,
il s'en sert, sinon c'est con.
Je comprends pas...
Thomas, je sais que ça doit
te faire un choc, mais oui,
je viens du futur et je voyage
d'époque en époque.
- J'en reviens pas !
- Je voulais pas te le dire.
On n'est plus en couple...
Sa capacité à accepter
le voyage dans le temps
est impressionnante.
- Il me faut de l'eau.
- Euh... C'est pas de l'eau.
C'est de l'eau-de-vie.
Iris, ton père
a vraiment disparu.
Tous ceux qui voyagent laissent
des traces temporelles.
On peut les localiser et voir
par où ils sont passés.
Mais le Docteur Simon,
plus rien.
Impossible de savoir où il est.
Tu crois que mon père est...
Est décédé ?
Eh ben, moi, je trouve
que toi, avec ta robe de reine,
tu ressembles plutôt
à la reine des sal...
Non, je pense
qu'il est encore en vie.
J'ai été activé à distance
par ton père.
J'ai pensé que c'était
pour que je lui serve un café.
Je l'ai cherché, mais il était
introuvable au laboratoire.
J'ai pris la dernière machine
à voyager dans le temps
pour essayer de le localiser.
Impossible.
Alors je me suis dit
que tu savais peut-être
où il était.
Attendez, la statue qui brille,
elle a pas bougé, là,
vous avez vu ?
C'est un chevalier en armure,
Thomas.
Ma reine, je peux l'éliminer
d'un coup d'épée,
si vous voulez.
C'est très tentant, j'avoue,
mais non.
KB-28,
je vais vérifier ton histoire.
Ma machine à voyager est
dans mes quartiers, suis-moi.
Eh ben, KB-28,
il s'appelle Eliot, d'abord.
Sinon, c'est robot-phobe,
parce que...
je sais plus pourquoi.
C'est pas une machine
à qui on donne des ordres.
Eliot, tu peux me porter
sur ton dos ?
Le sol, il arrête pas de bouger.
Ton taux d'alcoolémie
est très élevé.
Monte, Thomas.
C'est bien. Gentille machine.
J'ai pas de nouvelles
de mon père depuis un moment.
Tu sais qu'on s'entend
pas très bien.
Peut-être que ma machine pourra
le localiser plus facilement.
- Aliénor ?
- Oh, ma reine ! Vous ici !
Tu fais quoi, ici ?
Tu dois nettoyer les latrines,
pas ma chambre !
Euh... je passe juste un coup
de plumeau, rien de plus.
Mais je m'en vais.
Elle a l'air louche, la dame.
Iris, elle tient la machine
dans son dos.
J'ai envie de revomir.
Quoi ?
Aliénor, lâche ça tout de suite.
Dame Iris,
j'ai percé votre secret.
C'est à cause
de vous et de cet objet magique
que les malheurs sont tombés
sur mon mari et moi-même.
Rends ma machine
avant de faire une connerie.
Vous êtes démunie, désormais.
Je vais pouvoir récupérer
mon trône en pressant
les boutons
de cette boîte magique.
Aliénor...
- Maintenant, Dame Iris...
- Aliénor !
Mettez-vous à genoux
et demandez-moi pardon
pour l'injure
que vous avez portée
à notre famille.
- Oh, la dame, elle est partie.
- Oh, la conne !
Elle s'est téléportée
avec ma machine.
- C'était qui ?
- Aliénor de Castille.
La reine du château.
Elle a les boules, parce que
quand je suis arrivée,
j'ai fait emprisonner le roi
et je lui ai filé
un boulot de servante.
Et je regrette, parce que
cette conne a pris ma machine !
Eh ben, c'est bien fait
pour ta gueule de lâcheuse.
Oh, j'en peux plus,
faites-le taire.
J'ai quelque chose
qui peut le réveiller.
Ah oui, c'est vrai
que tu fais du café.
Ça va lui faire l'effet
d'un coup de fouet.
- C'est de moi que vous parlez ?
- C'est pour toi, Thomas.
Oh, le taser !
C'est encore mieux.
Depuis quand t'as ça, toi ?
Je me suis ajouté
cette fonctionnalité
avant de partir.
Putain, mais Eliot,
t'as failli me tuer !
C'est génial !
- Un cappuccino ?
- Euh... Volontiers.
C'est vraiment le moment ?
Bon, un déca pour moi.
Très bien.
Ah, y a le dessin d'une fleur
dans la crème,
c'est mignon, Eliot.
- Merci.
- Bon alors, KB...
- Euh... Eliot, c'est ça ?
- C'est chaud.
Bon, on va devoir utiliser
ta machine
pour retrouver mon père.
Est-ce que t'as des traces
de lui avant sa disparition ?
Oui, il a beaucoup changé
d'époque, avant de disparaître.
- Mais j'ai tout enregistré.
- Parfait !
Voilà ce qu'on va faire :
on se barre du Moyen Âge,
on dépose Thomas chez sa mère
à son époque.
Ensuite, on suit les traces
de mon père.
On cherche des informations :
ce qu'il faisait,
avec qui il échangeait...
Peut-être
que ça nous mènera à lui.
Comment ça, je rentre chez moi ?
Bah, c'est dangereux de voyager
dans le temps, et toi...
Ah, j'en suis pas capable,
c'est ça ?
Je peux être super utile.
Et en même temps, on peut
en profiter pour clarifier
notre situation, c'est pas mal.
Je vois que tu t'en fous
de mon père
et que tu veux juste
être avec moi ?
Ah, c'est ton père
qu'on cherche ?
Non, parce que...
Ah oui, j'étais bourré.
Je suis l'homme de la situation
pour retrouver ton père.
Qui doit être quelqu'un
de très charmant.
C'est un con.
Eh, comment tu parles
de mon beau-père ?
Désolé de vous l'apprendre
comme ça, mais j'ai plus assez
de batterie pour voyager
dans le temps.
Oh non, ne me dis pas
qu'on est coincés ici.
J'ai puisé dans mes réserves
avec mon taser.
Voilà, ça,
c'est une mission pour moi.
Tu vas voir,
je suis indispensable.
Euh, alors... Voyons...
On peut savoir
ce que tu fais, là ?
Je cherche des prises.
Non, mais tu te doutes bien
qu'il y a pas de prise, ici !
On est en 1314.
Ou alors
peut-être derrière le lit...
Ah non, je sais, j'ai vu ça
dans un documentaire à la télé.
On va sur le toit d'une mairie
quand il fait de l'orage,
on met un câble
entre l'antenne et Eliot,
on attend qu'il fasse
un éclair...
Thomas, ça, c'est le film
"Retour vers le futur".
Iris, as-tu
un petit objet électronique ?
Ça suffirait largement.
Mais oui !
J'ai un téléphone portable.
Je l'ai filé au roi
en échange de son royaume.
Il est dans les cachots.
Il a lâché son royaume
en échange
d'un téléphone portable ?
Ouais, y a des vidéos porno
dessus, ça l'a rendu dingue.
Dès qu'il m'a filé sa place,
je l'ai fait emprisonner et j'ai
réduit la reine en esclavage.
On y est !
Attends, tu regardes
du porno, Iris ?
Bah, ouais,
comme toutes les filles.
Ah, les filles du futur
regardent du porno ?
Non, les filles
regardent du porno.
Mais nous, dans le futur,
on le dit.
Oh non !
Il faut frapper avant d'ouvrir.
C'est moi, ou le roi
a son pantalon baissé ?
Parce que là,
je vois toute sa...
J'ai dit qu'il fallait frapper
à la porte !
Encore merci, ma reine,
pour la pierre plate magique,
et les images
de femmes qui bougent.
Est-ce qu'il peut remonter
son pantalon ?
Parfait, Iris.
Ce téléphone fera l'affaire.
Non, non ! Non, non !
Rendez-moi les images.
Je veux voir les femmes
sans poils.
Iris, c'est horrible,
ce que tu fais au roi.
Découvrir le porno
et en être privé juste après,
ça doit faire très mal.
Ma reine !
Le peuple est révolté !
Ils veulent votre tête
et récupérer le roi !
Quoi ?
Mais pourquoi ils se révoltent
d'un coup, là ?
C'est une chanson
qu'ils ont apprise
qui leur a ouvert les yeux.
Un chant révolutionnaire.
Ah, mais...
C'est la chanson de Thomas !
Ah, mais ouais,
c'est ma chanson.
Bah, vous voyez, je peux être
utile, les gens m'écoutent.
Pas du tout, ils veulent
me couper la tête !
Et je déteste cette chanson,
en plus.
C'est en partie pour ça que j'ai
quitté ton époque, Thomas.
Ah, donc on est
toujours ensemble ?
C'est bon, j'ai vidé
la batterie du téléphone.
- On peut quitter cette époque.
- Oh, enfin une bonne nouvelle !
Mon cher roi, j'ai le plaisir
de vous annoncer
que vous récupérez
votre royaume.
- C'est cool, hein ?
- Le royaume ne m'intéresse pas.
Je veux la pierre plate
avec les femmes nues.
Oh, les révolutionnaires !
Ils arrivent !
Ils ont déjà exécuté
la moitié du château !
Oui, bon, bah, démerdez-vous.
Nous, on se casse.
KB, euh... Eliot.
Où est allé mon père ?
J'ai quelque chose à...
Berlin, en... 1944.
Oh non...
Bon, bah, c'est parti.
Pourquoi, il...
Il se passe quoi, là-bas ?
Mais t'es vraiment nul
en Histoire.
Oui, bah, ça va !
Je voyage pas dans le temps pour
apprendre tous ces trucs, moi.
Il suffit d'aller à l'école,
merde !
Eliot, cassons-nous.
Tiens, le roi.
Il reste 2 % de batterie,
amuse-toi bien.
Oh, merci, Dame Iris...
Oh, mille mercis !
J'ai synchronisé la trace
temporelle du Docteur Simon.
Restez près de moi.
Direction l'Allemagne.
Retemporalisation immédiate.
Bon, bah, c'est parti !
Ah, oui, c'est la guerre,
en fait.
Bien vu, Thomas.
C'est même
la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
comme on l'apprend
dans le programme de 4ème.
Désormais, cher auditeur,
tu en sais plus
sur la quête d'Eliot.
Il faut retrouver
le Docteur Simon,
l'inventeur de la machine
à voyager dans le temps.
Vont-ils le retrouver ?
Écoute le prochain épisode.
Moi, je sais déjà tout,
je te l'ai dit.
- Mon roi !
- Frappez à la porte !
On vous libère.
Vous êtes libre, tout va mieux.
- Désor...
- Oh non...
Vous avez votre pantalon baissé.
Les images ont disparu !
Oh, les femmes !
Où sont les femmes ?